HERE'S CHYCHRUN. IT.
DOZEN SECONDS TO GO AS THE PASS
TO LONG TYPE SINCE HE
WENT THIRD OVERALL BACK IN OFF
SEGUIN WHO FEEDS KERO AND HIS
SHOT DEFLECTS
FISCHER TAKING A COUPLE OF LOW
CROSSCHECKS FROM SUTER.
TURNOVER INTO A CHANCE NEAR THE
NET LICKETY SPLIT. AND  KILL
ONON FORWARD, KEITH
TKACHUK WAS BACK IN THE DAY.N T.
SEKERA.
ROBERTSON WILL TURN AND LOT IN
GAME WAY BACK IN 2012.
STOPPED BY WEDGEWOOD,
IMMEDIATELY THEY SPUN  STARED A
REFEREE.
>> Daryl: HIS DEFENSEMAN,N BY
LYUBUSHKIN.
GOOD PLAY FROM HIS KNEES TO KEEP
DZINGEL.
BACK FOR KELLER.
QUICKLY OVER TO CHYCHRUN.: MIROE
OF THOSE ROUGH SHIFTS WHERE HE
WAS GOING THE WRONG DIRECTION A.
THE STARS WERE VERY PATIENT,
ZONE.
FROM THAT